Nancy Pelosi breaking news Nancy Pelosi
has yammered on about nothing
in order to subvert our laws and
undermine the constitutional order for
about 37 years most recently speaking
for 8 hours and 7 minutes setting a
record for bloviating in the House of
Representatives we will analyze her
accomplishment then Liz wheeler and
Ariel Davidson joined the panel of
deplorable zh-- to discuss Donald
Trump's making the National Prayer
Breakfast great again the FBI informant
who says Russia paid millions to bribe
then Secretary of State Hillary Clinton
on the uranium one deal and the
mainstream media's breathless reporting
on some fringe racist running as a
Republican for Congress in the D plus 6
district he's guaranteed to lose and in
which no serious candidate would ever
waste his time and money running do you
see you see Republicans are evil do you
see finally the mailbag I'm Michael
Knowles and this is the Michael Nolt
show
[Music]
so before we get to this there's a lot
going on before we talk about this
ridiculous display that people are
completely getting wrong they don't
really understand at all what the
historical context is for Nancy Pelosi
running her mouth which she's been doing
for decades and decades but she did for
eight hours yesterday before we do that
we need to thrive we need to talk about
the rive this is a much nicer news than
Nancy Pelosi thrive market is my new
favorite online store now you know you
know this obviously I'm here I'm in the
broom closet of the ben shapiro show I
occasionally they'll give me some water
to drink but it's not like I get a
paycheck or anything the one nice aspect
is I sometimes will get a product so
that I can eat them and occasionally I
have sustenance when I'd come home from
the office thrive market is my new
favorite online store they sell all the
top organic and healthy products at
twenty five percent to thirty to fifty
percent off shipped straight to your
door next to each product
it shows retail price versus thrive
market price so you can see exactly how
much you're saving these are the best
quality products thrive has all of the
top premium healthy and organic products
I usually get them from the grocery
store but it's not like I'm gonna drive
to the grocery store this is 2018 fellas
I ain't doing that unlike your typical
organic and non-gmo products that are
marked up to premium prices thrive
market sells the same organic and
non-gmo premium products at wholesale
prices you know and for most of my life
I've subsisted on a diet of fatty
Italian meats and whiskey that's been
most most of my life and you're starting
to see the effects of it it's not
looking good I'm trying to eat a little
bit healthier and probably everybody
should too so are you looking for
specific quality when it comes to your
food and household item whether it's
non-toxic bpa-free non-gmo no artificial
ingredients safer for kids you can
easily find these values on the thrive
market site for each product how do they
do that thrive markets cuts out the
middlemen they work directly with the
brands and they can pass all the savings
on to their members even better for
everyone who signs up thrive market
donates a membership to a low-income
family a veteran or a teacher so
together we're all making healthy living
affordable for everyone
when you sign up because you know you
can afford it you're listening to this
show you probably have several smoking
jackets and you know sip brandy out of
snifters and everything at night not
everybody can do that all the time so it
also goes a long way to making sure that
healthy eating is available to everyone
and it's a company that I'm honored to
support easier than the grocery store
thrive makes it easy to shop online
their site is tagged by over 90
different values so in one click you can
sort the entire catalogue by all of
those categories non-gmo organic vegan
gluten free paleo sustainably farmed on
and on and on you now it's all curated
this is what's nice too so if I look at
these websites I I can't decide what the
best extra extra SuperDuper virgin olive
oil is I don't know what how am I going
to know so it's all curated there you
may find only two to three olive oils on
thrive market
but you can trust their options will be
sourced from the best of the best
ingredients at the most affordable
prices
they do all the homework for you which
is very good for me because I try you
know I try to sleep about 17 18 hours a
day the time I have available for
productive work pretty low so it's a
nice the Thrive will do that all for you
today just for my listeners get sixty
dollars of free organic groceries sixty
dollars of free stuff do it plus free
shipping so they're not even gonna say
you have to pay a gazillion dollars for
shipping and the discount goes away you
get sixty dollars of free organic
groceries and free shipping and a 30-day
trial membership you'd be foolish not to
do this this is just free food with
absolutely no risk and absolutely no
cost so do it and don't say I never did
anything for you go to thrive market
calm slash michael mi CH AE l keep in
mind that thrive markets prices are
already twenty five to fifty percent
below retail cuz they cut out the
middleman now they're offering you $60
some free stuff on top of that plus free
shipping if you do not go you are a fool
so do it
so ride market calm slash michael
listeners get $20 off their first three
orders of $50 or more plus free shipping
and the average order value is 60 bucks
so $49 should be easy especially when
you see all of these great prices so
thrive market calm slash Michael okay we
got a lot to get to so let's get right
into it Nancy Pelosi spent all day
yesterday yammering away not exactly
veidt's dog story but she set a record
for the longest speech in the Chamber's
history what was she talking about well
it must have had something to do with
the topics Americans really care about
right the economy government corruption
after all those damning FBI texts from
the Obama administration the evidence
that Russia paid off Hillary Clinton as
Secretary of State
maybe was about health care reform law
and order terrorism right something like
that
no take it away Nancy as members of
Congress we have a moral responsibility
to act now to protect dreamers who are
the pride of our nation in our American
every way but on paper our young people
are our future and these dreamers are
part of that no of course that's what it
was about
on the contrary to anything that matters
despite nearly 70% of Americans
according to a morning consult Politico
poll saying amnesty for illegal aliens
should not be a priority for Congress
despite even the majority of Democrats
saying that amnesty for illegal aliens
should not be a priority
Nancy spoke for over eight hours about
how we need to subvert the rule of law
and give amnesty to between 1.8 million
and 3.6 million people according to
Pelosi illegal aliens brought here under
18 some of whom are 40 years old now
they are the pride of our nation she
says half of them don't speak English a
quarter of them can't read but they're
American in every way except on paper
and except all the other ways she is
right when she says that these illegal
aliens who were brought here under 18
are our future but we've got to be
careful of the word hour-by-hour she
doesn't mean Americans we think she
means America she doesn't buy our she
means Democrats few research indicates
that 75 to 90 percent of the so-called
dreamers if given amnesty would vote for
Democrats what a dream indeed 1.8
million people on the low end 3.6
million on the high end that's what this
is all about
that's why Nancy Pelosi is so impatient
she won't get impassioned about people
losing their health insurance she won't
get an impassioned about people losing
their jobs she can't she doesn't care
less about that she gets him passionate
about getting millions of new voters
that's what this is all about destroying
the Republican Party forever
she's so passionate about that she broke
a hundred nine-year record
and spoke for a full workday to see it
through but a stankin acknowledged the
dreamers for their courage their
optimism and their inspiration to make
America more American make America more
American half of the group doesn't speak
English and 1/4 can't read Amnesty would
make America more Latin American it
would make America more left-wing it
would make America less free by
subverting democratically enacted
immigration law and telling a free
people that they have no right to run
their own country that they have no
right to expect law and order the rule
of law in their country
now unsurprisingly the winds blowing
record she broke belonged to another
Democrat a man named champ Clarke 1909
although back then the Republicans had
the good sense to interrupt this sort of
nonsense so given that it's unclear if
his speech actually held any record a in
true Democrat fashion he was speaking
against tax reform a tariff overhaul
that gained steam earlier the year
earlier and he wasn't all that bad
actually I looked into a champ a little
bit
apparently champ thought Woodrow Wilson
for the Democrat nomination of 1912 he
opposed the federal reserve and he
wanted to annex Canada saying quote I
look forward to the time and the
American flag will fly over every square
foot of British North America up to the
North Pole so yep pretty good actually a
mixed bag not altogether a bad guy I'm
sorry that his record got broken there's
another aspect to this isn't it a little
bit strange that we don't have great
records for these house speeches you
know we think below seas is the longest
since 1909 we're not really quite sure
we don't see these hours long speeches
very much in the house that's because
they don't serve any purpose I know it
seems like they serve purpose we see
things like this in the Senate but they
don't serve a purpose they call
attention to some issue maybe but
there's no practical purpose the Senate
has a filibuster the house does not even
if the house did have a filibuster
Pelosi did it wrong the filibuster is a
tactic we're in a politician indulges
his favorite melody the sound of his own
voice for long periods of time to delay
or entirely prevent a decision to be
made on a given
proposal so you'll remember Ted Cruz did
this in 2013 Ted Cruz's 2013 filibuster
was to delay the decision to fund
Obamacare that the house actually did
have a filibuster until 1842 at which
point a permanent rule limiting the
duration of debate was created this is
because the house got too large so the
original size of the House of
Representatives was just 65 people today
there are 435 representatives in the
house if the filibuster were allowed in
the house nothing would ever get done
even less than is now but this is what
we get out of a shallow and superficial
culture we don't get a real filibuster
about a real issue that affects real
Americans instead we get a fake
filibuster about a glib euphemism like
dreamers that only pertains to non
Americans we get the appearance of
serious governance without any actual
seriousness she didn't even do the
filibuster right what she should want is
not to delay a vote should want to vote
right now she didn't even do it right
all of this we got to benefit Democrat
politicians and foreign nationals is it
any wonder that make America great again
resounded with voters absolutely not
we've got to bring on our panel to talk
about the news but we and we've got oay
ends Liz wheeler here we've got Ariel
Davidson and before we get to that
though I I do have to acknowledge this
you might see this this is on my desk I
got some nice beautiful flowers here I
didn't know who they were from
I assume they were from sweet little
ELISA that absolutely not know that not
a chance
and I saw I got a card from Drew and it
was a little cord it drew send me these
flowers obviously to apologize for every
single weekend for the last two to three
years he has ruined my weekend every
time he made me watch Barry the Barack
Obama movie he made me watch the south
side with you I've had to go to women's
marches I've being a cultural
correspondent on his show has been
really really tough it's it's that one
moment of Solace you know the weekend
he's just destroyed every time so I want
to thank drew for the for the lovely
roses it's pretty sweet of you you know
girl always likes to get roses and these
came from 1-800 flowers so living
dangerously can be a thrill but waiting
until the last minute to purchase a
Valentine's gift that is playing with
fire
why Dru knows to get these early earlier
than I have I have to get some now too
for sweet little ELISA so don't delay go
to 1-800 flowers dot-com
that's 1-800 flowers it always has your
back in these tough situations right now
you can get 18 enchanted roses I am
enchanted drew has enchanted me with
these roses for only $29.99 that's
actually that is a really good deal I
send flowers around a fair bit I have
family all over the country and they'll
send flowers sometimes that is a great
deal eighteen enchanted roses for only
$29.99 go to 1-800 flowers calm I guess
you've got to use the code Clavin que la
vie a.m. he gave me the flower so you
should use his promo code keep the
lights on in their 1-800 flowers calm
promo code Clavin order it today alright
thank you drew that was very very sweet
of you excellent ladies thank you very
much for being and this is really nice
you know after a bald man from the next
room gave me my Valentine's flowers it's
nice to see your face this is balancing
things out a little bit thank you for
being here today is the National Prayer
Breakfast Trump's comments at the prayer
breakfast president Trump's comments
include we can all be heroes to
everybody and they can be heroes to us
as long as we open our hearts to God's
grace America will be free the land of
the free the home of the brave and the
light to all nations America is a nation
of believers and together we are
strengthened by the power of prayer our
rights are not given to us by men our
rights are given to us from our Creator
no matter what no earthly force can take
those rights away compare those comments
with Nancy Pelosi a few years ago
13 15 and 17 we know that this message
this command of love is not confined to
the New Testament the same message
stands at the center of the Torah and
the teachings of the Prophet Muhammad -
from the Torah it says love your
neighbor as yourself and from Muhammad
none of you has faith until he loves for
his brother or his neighbor what he
loves for himself
jaren notice these democrats they always
call Muhammad the Prophet Muhammad as
though he but I don't think he's our the
Prophet most people on earth don't think
he's the Prophet we they don't refer to
the Messiah Jesus do they do they were
how about after that Barack Obama's
obtuse and historically ignorant
babbling at the prayer breakfast himself
unless we get on our high horse and
think this is unique to some other place
remember that during the Crusades in the
Inquisition people committed terrible
deeds in the name of Christ so we'll get
to that in a bit because also nonsense
Liz so many on the Religious Right have
held Donald Trump at arm's length
because he joked with Billy Bush about
things that he likes to grab and he's
lived sort of a tabloid lifestyle should
Christians in America embrace President
khofifah okay a couple of things first
of all I did some research and I hope
we're allowed to disagree with you on
this show no because I don't know if
evangelicals actually have held
president Trump at arm's length here if
you look at Pew Research
they did a survey of evangelical voters
this was mid-year last year about six
months into the Trump presidency they
found that over 75% of evangelical
voters supported President Trump now you
might remember hearing on the mainstream
media that evangelical voters were
starting to starting to distance
themselves from the president that they
weren't as supportive as they were when
they cast their vote for him that was
propagated by Newsweek magazine who did
a survey in which they use in my opinion
very biased wording for their questions
they didn't ask
about the policies that Trump was
pushing they asked if voters if these
evangelicals would support President
Trump no matter what of course they got
of course they got a response that said
only 30% would support the president no
matter what it's a great question though
should Christians should we as
Christians I'm not saying you're telling
other Christians what to do I am telling
them what to do but I'm sorry for it yes
I think Christians should support
President Trump because all we have to
do is look at the policies that he's
implemented we just have to look at the
comparison which party right now in our
country is offering protection for
unborn babies offering to treat unborn
babies like the people that they are and
which party is saying no look you have a
right to and we should celebrate that
right to rip these babies limb from limb
that's and resell their limbs and sell
their organs don't forget that part
there is a market incentive to it right
but it's not just abortion we can look
at any of our rights our god-given
rights that President Trump was talking
about and we can ask ourselves which
party which President has protected that
well our First Amendment right to free
speech president Trump's protected that
our First Amendment right to practice
our religion the way that we deem best
not the way the government deems best
President Trump has already put
protections into place the Hobby Lobby
ruling appointing Supreme Court justice
Neel Gorsuch ruling back the
contraceptive mandate our right to
protect ourselves our Second Amendment
rights our families to bear arms
president Trump has protected that every
thing that he's done has been a
protection or just about everything he's
done has been a protection for our
god-given rights oh of course
no excuses for his character his bad
behavior but yeah as a Christian I
support President Trump that sounds
right to me it Liz and you know I do
notice in the Bible with the exception
of one man just about everybody that God
uses for good purposes is maybe a little
flawed maybe even more flawed than the
sort of fellow who jokes around with
Billy Bush and a lot of good things came
out of that too that is absolutely right
and you're right evangelical Christians
despite ridiculous fake polling I have
supported president from much more so
than Catholics and mainline Protestants
so that is certainly a point in there
eriell american politicians have for
decades extolled the alleged virtues of
islam and multiculturalism while they
flagellate christians for a defensive
war that took place 800 years ago about
which they know absolutely nothing
should American politicians be less
multi-culti and more vocally Christian
well I have two points to make on that
so I want to backtrack a bit to Obama's
comments I actually didn't have a huge
problem with policies comments but
Obama's comments at the 2015 prayer
breakfast really got to me in the sense
that you know this is a long along this
this follows a long thread of sort of
putting down the idea of American
exceptionalism or sort of shifting blame
onto America and so baked into the left
side eeeh of multiculturalism is at the
same time juxtaposed with putting down
America in some way and putting down
sort of you know majority Christian
nations and that to me is what's wrong
with what I would appreciate seeing is
actually along the lines of what Pelosi
was trying to say I think was a
celebrating religious freedom in America
which has always been the crux of
religious liberty in America is
celebrating the idea that you can
practice your religion freely whatever
your religion may be and I don't think
that needs to be in fact I think we
should be celebrating the idea that
we're united by this devotion to
protecting religious freedom that should
be what unites us I think that and that
message got very very polluted and lost
particularly by Obama when he made a
mission to show that you know American
exceptionalism America is not as
exceptionalism think it is no I think
America is wonderfully exceptional I
think and what makes us exceptional is
that we do give everyone the right to
practice their religion freely as long
as they're not harming others in the
process and so for me I actually you
know I took greater issue with Obama's
comments because I think you know his
and if we go back further into his
speech his response was actually um
directly related to sort of trying to
equalize you know radical Islamic terror
by saying no wait a minute you know the
Inquisition's and the Crusades were done
in the name of Christ
I think that's just completely
inappropriate it's the wrong setting to
be doing that and the reality is is that
you know radical Islamic terror is what
we are facing right now as a nation and
I would argue the greatest national
security threat that we are facing as a
whole it's not only down dev its he also
just misunderstands what he's talking
about I don't think the man knows
anything about the Crusades I don't
think he knows anything about the
Inquisition I think he's heard these
buzzwords and our country at the moment
is very lightly educated I think at some
point I'll have to do a show on the
Crusades and on the Inquisition because
no but if you read like one book about
this I think you know more than 99.99%
of people in the world it's very
frustrating and tone-deaf and of course
President Obama would constantly gloss
over the issues of Islam a religion that
has inspired attack against the West for
1,400 years and he would he would glide
over those and he would harp on any evil
that was ever done by someone who called
himself a Christian totally totally tone
deaf and it's a really nice shift that
I've seen alright ladies we got to move
we got to keep flying through this an
FBI informant named Douglas Campbell has
informed three congressional committees
that Russia paid millions of dollars to
a u.s. lobbying firm to bribe then
Secretary of State Hillary Clinton by
helping her husband's Foundation during
the Obama administration Liz we have
Barack Obama on a hot mic saying that he
will give Russia leeway after his
election they just had to lie to voters
to pretend to take a strong stance on
Russia we have Hillary Clinton
apparently being bribed by Russia while
Secretary of State and Democrats have
spent a year and change accusing Donald
Trump of being a Manchurian Candidate
for Vladimir Putin because some Russian
ran a Facebook ad or something are
Democrats accusing Republicans of
colluding with Russia explicitly to
cover up their own collusion with Russia
well of course they are
that's so Lewinsky is that's one of his
principles you accuse the your opponent
of doing what you were doing in order to
create Kalu or in order to create
confusion it's like little kids if they
get into a fight the one little kid's
gonna run to his mother and be like mom
he hit me well the other kid's gonna be
like nah he hit me the first person's
accusation is going to carry more
credibility the second one sounds like
copycat even if that person is lying the
funny thing to me here - is that Barack
Obama was the one who was condescending
and skeptical he made fun of Mitt Romney
in 2012 for saying that Russia was our
number one geopolitical foe well who's
laughing last now I mean we can see this
case but this story is funny to me too
because we already knew that this was
happening we already knew that the
Russians had tried to infiltrate Hillary
and Bill Clinton their organization
Hillary at the State Department that
they had corrupted nuclear entities in
the United States including that nuclear
trucking company that they had bribed
and given kickbacks to nuclear entities
in the United States in order to try to
infiltrate and get our nuclear secrets
to try to influence that which led as
convoluted as it sounds - the uranium
one deal so I don't know why we're
acting so surprised that the Russians
are trying to steal things from us and I
definitely don't know why we're acting
surprised that Hillary Clinton is
somewhere in the middle of this of
course of course
an aerial this leads to the inevitable
question should anybody in that Clinton
orbit go to jail and I don't think it's
as simple as it seems on the one hand of
course they should on the other hand do
we really want to set the precedent of
seeing failed presidential candidates
and their cronies go to the clink even
if they deserve it I think it's sort of
irrelevant if their presidential
candidates are not because I think as
soon as you start subvert of subverting
the law in order to keep the peace I
think that sort of is counterintuitive
and I actually think achieves the
opposite result because it shows that if
you are powerful enough if you are even
a failed presidential candidate no
matter what your past transgressions are
you can sort of be sure that you can
evade prosecution I don't think that's a
good precedent to set at all I think
irrespective of whether you know you're
an everyday citizen who you know is not
in the public sector or if you some or
if you are someone with tremendous clout
in the public in the public sector I
think we shall be treated equally in the
eyes the loss so in my mind it really
doesn't make a difference if you are
somebody who has the political clout of
the Clintons and I think that you know
you should uphold your duty as an
American citizen to obey the law Arielle
you've made me feel so much better I was
second-guessing
I thought do I need to advocate that we
don't send Hillary to prison and then
you you've you've opened my eyes in my
heart again thank you very much I
appreciate that ladies we have more news
to talk about but we're just running up
against the time today so unfortunately
I have to say goodbye to you if it were
up to me I would never say goodbye to
you I would have you on for the whole
show I would never have flowers from
Andrew Clavin but that's the way it goes
thank you both for being here
Liz wheeler from OAM and Ariel Davidson
ladies I will see you next time happy
Valentine's Day maybe I'll see you
before then okay we got to get to the
mailbag but before we get to the mailbag
sorry folks if you're on Facebook or
YouTube you got to you got to go to
daily wire comm I know well you're
probably not on YouTube because they
censor everything we do but you might be
on Facebook if you go to daily wire.com
what do you get you get me you get the
intro Clavin sure you get the Ben
Shapiro show you get the conversation we
released a saucy promo for that today
you might want to have some eye bleach
on hand depending on depending on how
you're watching it and you so you get
that you get the conversation you get to
ask questions in the mailbag you get to
ask questions in the conversation many
can watch but few can ask questions many
are called but few are chosen you can do
all of that your love meters are about
to spike because this Valentine's Day
and Wednesday February 14th at 5 p.m.
Eastern 2 p.m. Pacific we will be doing
a very romantic episode of the
conversation featuring the swarthy astir
at the Daily wire critical care unit and
that is me but unfortunately for you all
unless your subscribers you won't be
able to get it so go there right now
it's $10 a month $100 for an annual
membership you'll get me you'll get the
under Clavin sure you get the Ben
Shapiro show blah blah blah you'll get
them leftist tears tumblr you're gonna
need this Nancy Pelosi almost drowned
everybody in that House of
Representatives yesterday Wow Wow you're
not gonna give amnesty to three million
people who we're all gonna vote for my
party when you're not going to destroy
the Republican Party forever when wet
collects them they're going to be a
valuable vintage someday so be sure to
get the leftist ears tumblr go to daily
wire comm we'll be right back
a lot of good ones today so let's get
right into it the first question is from
Elinor hi Michael I've recently found
out a years-long friendship won't
survive the tax cut or at least won't
survive Trump I could use some advice on
dealing with the fallout is right now my
only option to save it is apparently to
apologize for my political beliefs and
that's not going to happen thanks good
don't apologize for your political
beliefs if they're right they're right
if they don't pretend that something
isn't true to appease some apparent
friend who doesn't seem to care that
much about real friendship friendship is
misunderstood these days Aristotle
writes about it in the Nick and McKeon
ethics and he says there are three kinds
of friendship there's a friendship of
utility friendships of pleasure and
friendships of the good so friendship of
utility is you can get something from
somebody you like politics right you
become political oh my good friend oh
yes my great friend Mitt Romney oh yes
my great whatever right
that's a friendship of utility a
friendship of pleasure is one where it's
convenient you know there's some nice
you you enjoy one little thing together
or whatever you have some little thing
in common maybe it's a college friend
you both like going to parties or
something but you don't have much there
afterward and then there's a friendship
of the good right no greater love hath a
man to die for his friends it's based on
willing the good of the friend and he of
you it is based on having good will so
yeah you know a good image of this is
the people who stand side by side one
another and they're looking at the same
thing it's a mutual appreciation of
virtues that the other party is holding
dear you might not have the same
opinions about the thing but you will
have the same goodwill the perfect form
of friendship Aristotle writes is that
between the good and those who resemble
each other in virtue for these friends
wish each alike the others good in
respect of their goodness and they are
good in themselves but it is those who
wish the good of their friends for their
friends sake who are friends in the
fullest sense since they love each other
for themselves and not accidentally
hence the friendship of these lasts as
long as they continue to be good and
virtue is a permanent quality
friendships are of course rare because
such men are few it seems if your friend
is is gonna cut you out because you like
tax reform or something it doesn't sound
like much of a friend to begin with
don't you you don't need to cut somebody
out but you know you certainly should
never compromise yourself or your
integrity or your view of the truth and
your your own view of the good just to
appease somebody who won't like you if
you have a differing opinion from John
well another Catholic question for you
all I've heard a few of these I'm having
trouble finding solace in Catholic
teachings my wife and I are in our late
30s and we're blessed with three
wonderful kids however we're in the
middle of our second miscarriage in two
years we'd love to have another child
but it is so painful losing a child
midway through I don't know what's in
the cards if we get pregnant again and
I'm too scared to want to try again
is it even fair to the future child to
try again the Church teaches away from
both non natural pregnancies and
contraception so what are we to do keep
saying goodbye to children we will never
know in this world enter a period of
chastity until we're too old to conceive
count our blessings with our three
healthy kids get snipped and go to
reconciliation pay big money for IVF is
not in the cards for us so that is one
option off the list for future children
I'm open to adoption but that still
leaves unaddressed the future sexual
relationship with my wife and the fear
of losing another child I'm sorry to
hear of your trouble of past couple
years the Catholic teaching on this as
you know is that you cannot close
yourself off utterly from the
possibility of children within marriage
but having children is not the only
purpose of sex 50 million Frenchmen can
be wrong but on this they're not wrong
the church teaches that there are two
purposes of sex within marriage unitive
and reproductive so the dilemma is that
some combination of your faith in your
wallet precludes condoms IVF abstinence
getting sniped all of those things
presumably more than just your faith and
while it's preclude that last one that
abstinence so you're clearly open to
more children but you're justifiably
afraid of another miscarriage and
another loss the method approved and
encouraged by the church natural family
planning might be your best bet people
mock this NFP as pull and pray they say
is they you're gonna definitely have
kids if you do it but actually when
followed it's up to
99% effective at avoiding pregnancy now
that still leaves open the possibility
of children the logical possibility of
children as the church enter bridegroom
require be fruitful and multiply that
sort of thing but nothing there's
nothing intervening artificially to
prevent children and yet given the
likelihood of pregnancy your age and the
effectiveness of NFP that may be your
solution and you won't lose the unitive
effects of that very very enjoyable act
best of luck and I hope you don't have
to go through that again from Ian dear
Michael I finished the newsroom a little
while ago and a couple things I took
away from it were one that the media has
left its main job of informing the
electorate in favor of this new
clickbait form of news the other is how
this generation has moved away from the
need for information we take everything
on Authority how do I move back into the
realm of facts so that I can grow
intellectually question everything
question everything there right now
there's this prevailing idea that if you
are skeptical of some claim that you're
an idiot if you're skeptical of the
global warming catastrophic global
warming you're an idiot there's nothing
stupid about being skeptical question
everything particularly the use of
language see how language is morphed and
twisted and perverted to push a
political agenda you see this dreamers
is the great example dreamers is now the
word we use to refer to a subset of
illegal aliens who are 40 years old or
younger and brought here under certain
circumstances that they don't dreaming
has nothing to do with the essence of
this political problem but they use it
as a euphemism to make us look like
jerks if we don't want to give the
dreamers amnesty and the Democratic
Party a permanent majority so be very
careful about that and watch all of the
language from Marcus Michael I own a
small business that serves a politically
mixed clientele Michael Jordan once when
asked his political views famously said
Republicans buy sneakers too how can I
support conservative values while still
attracting customers across the spectrum
I think owning a small business is a
conservative value isn't it isn't that
like in the in the list of them it is a
conservative value you don't need to
shove your politics down their throat
you're running a business the goal up
now it's very fashionable among
Millennials to say what's the purpose of
our business man what's the vision
what's the social
good we're all gonna do in this purpose
of the business is to make money and
offer a service to the marketplace or a
good to the marketplace that will
improve people's lives so just do that
if you do that and you don't have to pay
for abortions or something along the way
you'll you will be acting perfectly in
accordance with conservative values st.
Francis of Assisi said preach the gospel
and if you must speak I think that might
apply politically if you're doing
business the business of the American
people is business from Jake this is a
long one so I've shortened it a little
this might have to be the last one
Michael I'm a big fan a subscriber and I
consider this important what exactly are
you thinking with this idiotic
discussion on gays first of all your
discussion with father Michael Schmitz
wasn't about gay marriage it was about
how gay people should find strength in
Jesus to stay chaste now I don't know
how much understanding of what the
conservative movement has been through
on this but I was fighting for gay
rights in the GOP when you were in
middle school from a purely political
point of view quite literally no
decision by the GOP has been more
damaging to conservatives than the
decision to be hateful and
discriminatory to gays and make no
mistake that is what they were hateful
discriminatory unsympathetic the massive
tide in favor of gay rights did not take
place because we all decided to feel
instead of think genius it took place
because gay people finally felt safe to
begin coming out and naming themselves
by the millions for decades even
centuries most people didn't think they
knew a gay person suddenly they were
shown that they did and it's a lot
harder to be hateful to a group if you
find out that your brother best friend
or boss or favorite employee ism is a
member so the tide turned listening to
father Schmitz I felt like I was back in
the 90s or early 2000s all those ancient
days and then 2000 talking to someone
about this subject idiotic statements
like chastity can be fun and friendships
are great coming out of the mouth of a
person who chooses to be chaste for God
and somehow manages to think that
calling falls on people like me well mr.
Noles I suggest you do some more
research if you would like to understand
more about a sane all-caps position on
this I'm a conservative libertarian
gen-x are openly gay and begging at you
not to go down this road every new
argument about how it's not hateful to
keep gays from being married and how you
love the sinner but hate this
it's not new it's all been tried before
and it nearly destroyed conservatism and
will again if you insist on beating this
dead horse I'm a big fan and would be
happy to debate this over email or phone
it's a it's too important to be left
alone I agree that it is tui goes on and
says more mean things about father
Schmitz and he calls me hon I do agree
that this is too important to be left
alone that's why I'm talking about it I
must say I disagree with basically
everything you've just said but I'll
explain why I think you've missed the
basis of the argument of the
disagreement here where the conflict of
visions really lies to begin you say
that the discussion with father Schmitz
was not about gay marriage it was
explicitly about gay marriage in
particular one question what is marriage
not not who can get married not who
should have the right to get married not
who has the right to get married those
questions come later the crux of the
conversation is around one question what
is marriage then subsequent questions
follow does sexual difference have
anything to do with marriage maybe is
there a categorical difference between
men and women or are they those
differences just trivial and meaningless
and gender doesn't mean anything and men
and women are all exactly the same and
if there are real differences between
men and women perhaps might those
differences play some role in marriage
does marriage have something to do with
the logical possibility of procreation
what is marriage that's the question
it's the question that many people
angrily do not want to answer they want
to skip right ahead to the rights
question but you have to answer the
definition question first but that's
that's the hard one and I think that's
why advocates of redefining marriage try
to skip it you say that for decades and
centuries most people didn't think they
knew a gay person this seems to me an
example of a modern prejudice modern
pride there's this modern prejudice to
think that our generation discovered
everything including homosexuality but
we didn't ancient medieval modern
literature is replete with references to
gay sex and relationships the phrase
Elam oda italiano the Italian Way was
used to mean sodomy itself in the
sixteenth century maybe still today an
Italians are very very imaginative and
creative homosexuality has been around a
long time and all ages have known about
it and written about it but the crux of
our conversation really is not about
homosexuality at all and I think that's
where people are missing this point it
really isn't about the moral questions
or the practical questions of
homosexuality which mostly I don't care
about it was the nature of marriage
which is a question I do care about
because it's quite a political question
you use the phrase keep gays from being
married the question of our conversation
is what is marriage is it logically
possible to keep someone from being
married the question has nothing to do
with the morality per se whether you
think that gay sex is a grave moral sin
or you think that it is the best thing
since sliced bread neither has anything
to do with that question dude is sexual
difference sexual complementarity the
logical possibility of procreation do
those concepts have anything to do with
what is marriage you're of course right
that people should never be hateful or
discriminatory or mean or whatever
toward gay people that also has nothing
to do with the question that's a
distraction and a diversion to avoid
answering a simple question that might
have an inconvenient answer what is
marriage
proponents of redefining marriage or of
undefined marriage they find it
convenient to skip that they jump right
ahead we have to define our terms
if so elemental a question as what is
marriage can only be met with anger and
accusations of bigotry a question that
was easily answered until about five
minutes ago it is Justice Kennedy now
says the only reason to oppose radically
redefining or undefined marriage is
irrational hatred of gays irrational
animus if that's your immediate response
one must wonder whether the arguments
for redefining or under finding marriage
are really on sound logical footing or
if this is a matter of emotion running
away with us and and highlighting our
unwillingness to answer and deal with
simple but but difficult it's simple in
their in their clarity but difficult in
their effect on society and on culture
questions that we have to deal with
first before we can talk about rights
from Garrett
dr. Knowles alright we'll do one we'll
do one more right that's fine dr.
Knowles I often hear people sit back and
do nothing to influence their future
because God has a plan
however after studying good bit of
theology especially Catholic theology I
find this to be a misdirected belief I
can find few passages from Scripture
with the word plan but many with God's
will it seems to me and my priest that
God does not plan out your entire life
like the Calvinists might say but he
does have a will for your life instead
of betting on God's plan to hit you in
the face it's your job to transform your
mind body and soul to find God's will
for your life we're both interested in
your thoughts on our premise and if you
agree thank you yeah this is really good
advice you're right absolutely right gut
Andrew Clavin gave me this advice once
which is that God can't drive a parked
car you might have a will for your life
we can't drive a parked car and so there
was a you know I'm out here in Hollywood
I'm having trouble as an actor
especially as a conservative actor and I
will say the minute that I did anything
which was nothing I did nothing right I
did when I published a blank book I did
the physical equivalent of nothing a lot
of wonderful things followed because it
was it was at least almost doing if you
involve your will then then only then
can you match God's will you have free
will - God has a will and he gave you if
they will Dante referring to God in
heaven in his comedy uses the phrase
Dovie see what the Chokey see voila
where will and desire are United where
one can do what one wishes where he you
know he is up there who can do what He
wills this is the important juncture of
grace and Liberty you can turn away from
God or you can turn toward God well you
know we have a lot more questions to go
through we had some really good ones
unfortunately someone called me an
American heartthrob but do we have time
Rob doing time to do one we can do one
more all right let's just do one more
question I can't because they're gonna
be all these questions as a conversation
let's do this
this is the one from Chris and he called
me an American horth ruff American or
with Rob no holes it may you know if it
had said something else we wouldn't be
doing it it may come as a shock but I
have a question about Catholicism do you
know particularly the concept of papal
infallibility how are we supposed to
know when the Pope is infallible does he
tell us
do we just know it or is it something
that only God knows and we just have to
guess you are here clearly confusing
papal infallibility with the related but
different doctrine of Michael and FAL
ability and the former's when the Pope
speaks authoritative lis ex cathedra and
the latter is every single day on this
show when I speak infallible excoffier
a Vatican to teachers and fail ability
this way it says although the individual
bishops do not enjoy the prerogative of
infallibility they can nevertheless
proclaim Christ's doctrine infallibly
this is so even when they are dispersed
around the world provided that while
maintaining the bond of unity among
themselves and with Peters successor and
while teaching authentically on a matter
of faith or morals they concur in a
single viewpoint as the one which must
be held conclusively this authority is
even more clearly verified when gathered
together in an ecumenical council they
are teachers and judges of faith and
morals for the universal Church their
definitions must then be adhered to with
the submission of faith so if that
didn't clear it up for you
the doctrine comes from Scripture Christ
says to Peter in John feed my sheep in
Luke he says I have prayed for you that
your faith may not fail in Matthew he
says you were Peter and on this rock I
will build my church and the gates of
Hell shall not prevail against it I will
give you the keys to the kingdom of
heaven and whatever you bind on earth
will be bound in heaven and whatever you
loose on earth shall be loosed in heaven
sometimes non-catholics point out that
Paul says that Peter did something wrong
is he's here this evidence that the Pope
isn't infallible but he didn't say that
Peter is pronouncing wrong things and is
preaching heresy he very clearly says
he's not acting in accordance with what
he's preaching so you hear that a lot
and Peter many times doesn't act in
accordance with he's preaching that's I
think a very important aspect of why
he's chosen and handed the keys to the
kingdom of heaven an infallible
pronouncement comes only when some
doctrine has been called into question
most doctrines have never been doubted
by the majority of Catholics now
infallibility is not impeccability the
the charism to speak infallibly on
matters of doctrine is not the same as
not sinning not being able to sin on
that point though it is worth pointing
out how impressive it is that the the
Pope's have been so holy so
history we always hear about the bad
Pope's but the only reason we hear about
them is they're so rare if they were
common you know we wouldn't talk about
Boniface the eighth whom Dante puts in
hell we wouldn't talk about the handful
of bad ones we would say they're all bad
right but they're clearly not it's
generally understood that the Pope has
spoken ex cathedra infallibly only twice
that was Pope Pius the ninth and put
Pius the 12th defining aspects of of
Mary the Immaculate Conception and the
Assumption in this case this isn't
defining something new the church
already believed this first millennia in
the face of modernity it defined the
dogma the Pope can also speak infallible
E in the ordinary Magisterium not ex
cathedra as when Pope Saint John Paul
the second defined the church's
prohibition against murder for instance
which included euthanasia and abortion
but this isn't exactly controversial the
church has never supported murder you
know it's not a it's never been a they
say ok the old guy supported murder but
now we don't support murder
it is generally a rule with metaphysics
that shallows are clear and profound
things are murky so the vast majority of
infallible teachings we already know and
agree with as for ex cathedra
pronouncements definitions of question
doctrine the Pope will make it clear as
they did in the 20th century I know that
doesn't fit into a soundbite but I think
I hope that clears up a little bit of
infallibility and and I promise you I
was speaking infallible Exe offa so you
can take that to the bank man everybody
have a good weekend you can still binge
another Kingdom and reclaim one's
another Kingdom on any any app it'll get
you ready for Valentine's Day some of it
gets a little saucy otherwise I will see
on Monday I'm Michael Knowles this is
the Michael nul show see them
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Marshall Benson executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey supervising producer Mathis Glover
our technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Alex zingaro audio is mixed by
Mike Cora Mina hair and makeup is by
Joshua ov era the Michael Noel's show is
a daily wire for word publishing
production copyright for word publishing
2018
you